ce soir comme on l'a dit on t'appelle
gras dur et c'est très important pour
toi ton association moncaut ce soir on
va jouer à pousser c'est gagné tut
entretien et tu vas jouer avec matthieu
delormeau
c'est très simple il va y avoir ici un
bon ils peuvent de développé couché qui
va être installé ou la tour à tour
soulever un poids si vous y arrivez tous
les deux on trace au poids de 10 kg
voilà le premier qui n'arrivent pas à
trouver la barre on l'a fait redescendre
à la faire descendre et lamont terme de
lots remontée a perdu si vous propose de
jouer pour la bonne cause chaque
développé-couché rapportera 500 euros
pour l'association va nous en mettre
d'accord j'allais devoir faire un petit
échauffement rapide avec une barre assez
légères à 50 kg je vais demander à
matthieu delormeau et gras dur d'aller
sur scène c'est le français
[Applaudissements]
alors radio face à matthieu delormeau ça
l'arrangé pas fait ça moi alors je vous
le dis on va jouer pour 500 euros à
chaque fois donc là on a et on a 50 kg
l'a alors là il n'y a pas 50 kg et 10 je
crois qu'il atterrissait ton domaine du
tunnel et ettakatol assez facile sac au
dos à ses parents qu'il a fait c'est le
rythme des marées on va démarrer avec
traduire une radio va dit raconte kg
c'est parti à chaque fois que les deux
lèvres ont là-bas il y aura sa solde
pour l'association n'est pas riche mais
là non non rien ne doit être fait qu'un
hockey est un jeu bien qu'ils veulent
attention ça va c'est tranquille au cul
voilà un match de lambeaux 50 kg on y va
tu vois et j'entends en 40
easy pour lui quand on monte on monte à
60 ans il ya déjà ça et mathieu il ya
déjà cinq cents kilos a pas été facile
on a tu fais faire maxime est bon batta
serais-tu maintenant tu veux je mets 10
2 m et 5 et 5 semaines mois moi je me
souleymane attention bien combien ce
sont les buy aux attentions 60 kg
mathieu tu veux démarrer les 60 km 500
encore ça sent encore salée la sauce
pour la soa et mathieu et la chase et
pour l'association gradueront rappelle
60 mère si c'est bon c'est pas de
traduire les fonds pour l'association en
tranches et gay du combo gras durs qui
fait un travail exceptionnel pour cette
association attention 60 kg ça mon sens
celui basé mon gras durs sa venue la
différence c'est bon 60 kg ces bourgades
[Applaudissements]
attention à 110 on va monter on va
monter à 70 moi monté crescendo à monter
à 70 les chéris on va installer la barre
à 70 kg on essaiera de monter à 100 kg
djoudi a sera plus pour gagner le
maximum d'argent pour l'association
est-ce qu'ils vont arriver matthieu
delormeau et gras dur mathieu tpr et mon
chéri tu veux faire tout de suite les 70
70 a d'autres derrière matthieu
delormeau se prépare on se retrouve dans
un instant les chéris profit de toutes
parts aux bottes aigle azur
pour l'instant je vous le dis on joue
avec matthieu delormeau matthieu
delormeau qui a deux passions dans la
vie
la musculation et vantex c'est vous
malheureusement plus à la salle pour
l'instant il ya mille euros puisque à
chaque fois que vous arrivez à lever la
barre tous les deux à faire une traction
on rajoute 500 euros pour l'association
on est à une barre à 70 kg vous avez
déjà peu lever une barre à 70 gauche
monsieur c'est bon c'est bon
[Applaudissements]
vas-y mon gras du rival est le disque à
80 cookies lire pierre creisson tu perds
ton slip les pêcheurs et un baquet de la
c1 amis et doussain demi de 2,4 je suis
pas d'accord c'est beau l'amitié tient
bon ok
on est à 1500 euros pour l'instant pour
l'association les chéris on va monter
encore de 10 à 80 après une bonne idée
lui 80 ouais il a aucune idée sa une la
nba voulait qu'on fasse des pompes après
1 81 81 à des pompes à fric et des
médias ont fait des ponts concours de
pâques autres la pompe à 100 euros
donc tu continues à transformer ou un
chaton away comment ça pas mal bref sa
peau elle va très bas si pas mal et bon
français abbas à l'halloween et les
spectateurs
on arrive à faire 80 kg et après on fera
la pompe à 100 euros
vous avez déjà fait des pompes à 100
euros une très bonne y attention
mathieu maton pas 100 euros c'est parti
mon chéri à 80 qui voit là ça va passer
encore tu veux mettre plus par là non ça
va j'ai ton énergie takm pas là ça va
c'est bon ça passe ça passe ça passe
mais c'est déjà un truc à vous dit en
fait cette traction
si la russie elle vaudra pas 500 euros
mais mille car il ya 90 et non pas 80 90
je vais faire un coup comme ça ouais
ouais la tête avec 40 +6 attention
graduera 90 pour 1000 euros pour
l'association enfants chez vous et du
congo mais coûteux savage pas tu peux
regarder d'ici alors la paix 90 parce
que je propose qu'on à 2500 euros gras
durs tu as une idée
ouais c'est quoi ton idée mathieu
c'était quoi le quartier s'ils assument
eux rien on fait les pompes
ouais la pompe à 100 euros donc tu
continues tu prends soin euros à chaque
fois sa force à essaie d'en faire la
lutte à chaque fois de la tête froide et
inventeur au moins son nom qui ce qu'il
veut sans pompe à 30 des morts
elle avait là-bas 30 bat 30 fois sans ça
fait 3000 bah oui ça va tu es blindés
c'est pour une essence
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mettez-vous là j'en fasse pas trop fait
ce que tu peux allez on y va
attend il transmet non les caméras sont
là ça serait bien que tu te mettes comme
sa forme la jambe mais ses jours voilà
c'est pas mal à tanga dur fais gaffe à
son attention attention c'est parti on y
va c'est parti alors il va à 206 traite
mais le vrai alors c'est plus facile les
jambes écartées que comme ça je
t'emmerde fans de 23 24 25 26 27 28 29
cros [ __ ] d'affaires de 345 6 37 38
le beau matthew thomas
[Applaudissements]
c
c'était pour l'association je voulais
pas mariés dans la gravure mais tu en as
fait combien vero plus de 560 60 que je
divise par cros et moi 40 avait 100 non
non non c'est on avait fait un jeu il
fallait que vous fassiez les deux mains
ça s'additionne pas non maintenant à
mano banon banamba n'ont donc ça fait 60
x 60 70 ça fait 60
ça fait 60 x 17 pour la sauce et je vous
le dis on va donner donc voilà on va
faire le calcul y avait combien 2500
plus et ben je veux dire on va donner
la société partenaire
mathieu c'est un coup de l'émotion a été
très bon